now I prepared another game to show you
but I was told that this game was
already covered by Grandmaster fine
goals so I switched to another one that
I like a lot it's a new game 2016 I
believe and this is played by wayy and
against a number one player from Czech
Republic David Nabarro so let's take a
look at this game efore d5 Knight f3
knight c6 this should be 5 what is the
name of this opening we Lopez right but
black says I don't want to go age 6 I
want to play this one very popular
opening the line here very you know a
lot of very very top grandmasters played
what is this called Berlin defense when
did this Berlin defense became very
popular you remember in which World
Championship match this became very
popular played by Vladimir Kramnik
Kasparov kramnik 2000 remember in London
this is when it became popular before
that people didn't know much about
Berlin after that became very popular
because kramnik had a lot of success and
basically revived this this opening line
d3 where he says no I don't want to go
for this end game you know the kind of a
little bit boring end game white appears
to be a little bit better but not so
clear Bishop c5 and now he took on c6
beat a c69 bitty to taking the pond it's
not not gonna work
I mean there are few things wife can do
I mean there's a check
take check taking the night pack 24 is
another possibility 24 Bishop III take
74 anyway this is not good for white
anyway it takes and g2 is hanging so you
cannot take the pawn
so just remember in this position don't
take the pawn okay just make sure you're
remembering that naívi a two castles 90
for putting pressure 97
we need to see white doesn't want to
castle yet he just wants to wait and may
possibly castle to the the queenside
here so we need to come say now this
pawn is already little bit well nervosa
black has to protect it so David Nabarro
went here this should be to see more
very often we see Bishop actually coming
to c3 in these positions because that
way he can put pressure only five and
he's gonna be helping with a default
break Bishop d6 black is defending it h4
Bey is a very aggressive player he is
I believe he's 16 or 17 years old and he
is playing for the Chinese the team at
this upcoming Olympia which is starting
tomorrow so by many he is considered
very strong candidate to be a future
world champion because he's huge you
know he's very young and tremendously
talented so he played very aggressive
the h4 c5 basically black is trying to
shut down any break on d4 way he
continues now he wants to wage six and
usually if you get a pollen h6 it's a
good thing for you because that's gonna
be a pawn wedge it's gonna be a strong
fan sitting there and he's likely to
block it with g6 but then it's gonna be
annoying Queen getting on g7 so it could
be some some serious problems okay so
that's why he goes h6 fixing the pot and
now
won't castle so he's intention of
delaying the castle link now it's it
become clear now that he wants to go
long castle and he just wants to go
after David navara and that's why this
is a really nice game David noir is
himself a very sharp Graham mouw's very
sharp player the guy's capable of
beating anybody but in this game he just
could not withstand the pressure here
that we put on him Knight b8 I know this
moon looks kind of strange but this is
actually a typical move Knight wants to
go back to c6 go to c6 and then on d4
because often times black has trouble
what to do with this night
another alternative now after the game
I'm thinking maybe night FA would have
been a little bit of safer choice and
then put the pawn on f6 and just put a
knight only six that way at least he
could restrain you know I think I think
he kind of overestimated his chances
this is how I would try to go maybe
slightly worse but rock-solid I mean he
can really go g5 here with a knight on
his six so I think this this Knight b8
was bit it over optimistic move by David
Nabarro
yes Alex
actually no I don't think at the very
top level they lately started to play
this way against this it doesn't really
give white much advantage but this h4 h5
is a bit unusual plant yeah I've never
seen it before normally they go cows are
short and it's kind of solid dynamic
position but it's more solid but here he
is is looking for some complications
that's why I did no I think he just it's
possible he actually just analyzed this
setup with h4 h5 and putting the Queen
on the tube and just you know it's
possible he was still in preparation but
maybe it is definitely a move that it's
just too slow it's just too slow and
that's why it's not gonna work here
neither fate would have been my choice
slightly worse perhaps with rock-solid
to get this position neither fate here
f6 yeah midnight is gonna come to a5 but
at least he doesn't have a 4 he doesn't
have g5 and I will regroup put the
bishop on f8 put the knight on d4 bishop
on e6 I think it's playable so you'll
see now he went here and now
rook did you ban very simple very direct
plan for way in this game nice c6
I don't think bishop hg food is gonna do
anything because 93 comes in kicking the
bishop and then possibly going to f5 g4
f6 ok if look if white cannot play a g5
in this position this home up opening
concept is actually quite questionable
because if black plays Bishop f8 now and
Bishop e6 he is actually perfectly fine
so this position is not all the oldest
is done for one purpose to play g5 now I
want to pause here and give a little bit
of time to think because it's a crucial
moment in this game and see if you can
find the winning continuation
if there is one white to play do you
think g5 works here if you analyze the
encapsulated line it's not just
intuitively yeah because it's concrete
okay what did you calculate it does it
first of all this g5 work here
intuitively she says yes okay what line
did you calculate okay did you calculate
it this move then see you have to
calculate because don't always calculate
the most obvious moves right you have to
look at him counter playing yeah that's
what he's doing with 94 he wants to get
the good counter play now he's attacking
your queen yes if he takes back you go
Bishop g5 and h6 and probably gonna meet
him what do you do against 94 cuz you
playing David Navarra
27:30 player here that's cool in between
yeah attack 94 attacking the Queen not
just capturing the piece here first we
have to find a score for our queen yeah
and if you don't put in the right square
then it might be some problems
Queen f1
windy one because he wants to control
those light squares okay now now what it
took
now we are to clear but
I'm curious I I haven't analyzed this
position deeply but I'm curious if black
had some kind of a defense here after
take he got into some really serious
trouble here just wondering if move like
rook afraid would have been interesting
here don't think I think taking was the
strongest thing to do you know I feel
like something like this would make
sense know where h3 ok I go King h7
let's say am I really losing here look
very clear yeah yeah I yeah David is
noir is very principled player so he he
probably just look at some wise he says
you know what I'm just gonna take the
piece I don't see how am I gonna lose
and some people do that if they don't
see a clear way to lose they just take
the piece but now he is proving it
there should be five attacking the Queen
he goes Bishop e7 trying to exchange the
bishops now they should be three it's
possible in his calculations perhaps he
underestimated this strong retreat and
now the e5 pawn is hanging and also h6
looks very very comfortable okay so he
goes Bishop f6 navara is holding he's
trying to hang on to this position h6
comes in now trying to completely
eliminate that shield on g7 exchange
that time and now barking is going to be
in trouble so Luke is 7
takes rook g7 Queen h5 activating his
queen now threating some serious checks
here but here it's already becoming
clear that David Nabarro overestimated
his chances in this game Bishop e6 I
think it's a logical move just try to
develop the piece and also take on c4
that's what is trying to do just develop
some more pieces and now what is the
winning move here or the winning
continuation Bishop h6 you could go up
in h7 but I think after King f7
the queen is gonna be hanging you still
have some good attack there but I think
Bishop h6 is stronger because now you're
putting pressure on the rock now you're
threatening simply to take on g7 and you
have Queen h8 or you have Queen h7 check
okay so Bishop h6 you're putting
pressure on the rock now goes Bishop f7
attacking the whites Queen
I'll just calculate just calculate a
long line here yes there's also some
some 92 checks later on yeah so you have
to calculate a little bit deeper this
line here
okay what's the move capture with the
bishop that's correct
now he by the way cannot capture with
the bishop because of which move
checkmate yeah checkmate on h8 so he had
to take the Queen check attack in a
queen king f8
now you have to take the quiz if he
takes back your bishop you just simply
take the roof so he has to go check King
b1 he takes it again you can you know
win the bishop and play up a pawn but he
wants more he wants a convincing victory
not just a pawn
how about take another pawn and now
here's Navarro Master Navarro reason
because II five this week he's gonna
lose it h5 Bishop is hanging the knight
is hanging so he's gonna lose lots of
material that's why he's simply the
zion.t okay he's losing lots of material
here so I think accepting the sacrifice
this was an important moment here and I
want to verify this
I think accepting the sacrifice I feel
like right here in this position black
has some chances here you know and just
taking taking was a problem right away
we got into and white in a very easy
play but if you play something like Luke
f8 at least immediately I don't see a
clear way how white is just gonna come
and just dominate this game I really
don't see like after rook f8 I mean what
is the word is a clear path to the
victory here so if you retreat King h7
you know then perhaps you have route g6
maybe yeah you have some trauma some
pressure still but still I think even
rook rook f7 maybe he can play yes your
question
Bishop f7 wind so you're suggesting to
take here I'm just taking the rook and
then check so you quick f8 she says Wow
okay and just this is gonna work okay
let me take that first I'm sorry you I
assume you're gonna take right know what
this I don't think you can survive like
this check I don't think you can survive
you it wouldn't be correct if you can
survive this kind of position check
that's what happens you have enough
pressure and one more attacker comes in
one more attackers joins in the action
and then that's it the game is over
all right and my just takes some pawns
and take material okay very good
so let's review this game and make sure
that you now remember the entire game
here so it takes Bishop f6 check
attend that he would have night after a
check he doesn't want that to happen why
allow why why put your king somewhere
where he can even check you why in
danger you know you don't want any in
danger you know your position all right
let's see it's only 28 moves I hope all
of you here now we remember how this
game was developed so I'm gonna I want
to see some people calling out the moves
okay
and all of it all of you should
participate if you know the moves okay
all of you okay all right okay younger
students are more active usually they
want to get the answers you know but I
recommend everybody okay first of all
okay we don't need to do the personal
b45 9 f3 okay name of this defense
everybody barely in defense
okay d3 ante berlin yeah anti burning
don't mix up a move order huh guys don't
mix up the move order it's very
important to keep the order okay
h4 I think this is this is a new idea I
believe this is probably what we analyze
this h4 h5 idea very interesting to try
to create some weaknesses c5 a very
interesting plan I have to say it's
fixing it you have to play h6 to fix in
otherwise you put upon h6 it's gonna
become what which pawn pawn wage okay so
remember you don't want to allow them so
now after you push h4 h5 it's pretty
clear right what you're going to do with
your King Castle queenside you're not
gonna cast a short after you play h4 h5
correct and now Knight b8
this move is bit over optimistic I think
bit over optimistic issue the product on
night f8 here in my opinion but Luke DG
one actually I like your g4 mo I
actually think this is a quite
interesting move good suggestion
very good suggestion because she wants
to go g5 directly after f6 you probably
have to play roof did you want anyways
but at least if he takes this is
actually looks very powerful for you did
you calculate Queen d7 the consequences
after this bolt no I think this is a
crusher this is the crusher no here
the Oneida v 9h 495 very strong so he
took on f3 yeah that's just bad so nice
6f 6 g5 trying to break through captures
94 and now you miss the smooth though
you didn't see this move it's very
dangerous when you sacrifice and
suddenly you miss one of these in
between moves because that changes the
dynamics of the position okay so it's
very important you don't just miss this
in between moves in your analysis okay
so important to see this ideas because
now you have to make a decision where to
put the Queen you have several options
f1 III e1 but the best one is correct
Queen d1 because queen is gonna be ready
remember when he played Queen h5
that's why Queen goes on d1 because he
envisioned that he is gonna go Queen h5
later yeah I think take is just losing I
think I think rook a fate would have
been a better resource here I think
that's just and it was quite easy now
because also Queen according to Queen d7
because there's Bishop f6 and there's h6
ideas so Bishop e7 just simply
retreating simply going Bishop e3 now
rating h6 and also threatening to win
the central pawn as well here he's down
a piece but yeah he's got actually one
pawn I believe he's got just one point
it's very strong girl so he goes Bishop
f6 and now how are you going to try to
open up the position if it was g6 year
of g6 look e7 takes
queen h5 everybody do you remember now
when why he went queen d1 in the
position when he was attacked to be able
to do what exactly to be able to put a
queen on a tribe alright Bishop e6 comes
in Bishop h6 removing the final defender
there and now forcing him to either you
know yes lose the rook or just take on
g1 and get made it so the best thing he
could find is to go [ __ ] have seven
other options are losing as well and now
you just need to calculate it Bishop
takes Bishop takes if he takes that
leads to a maid on h8 perfect so he
takes on h5 check da he gives you
another check your check first you have
to move here they should take c7 and
here he resigned because he's gonna pick
up the pawn on e5 and so excellent game
by wayy I mean his his had an excellent
year the previous year was also very
good for him so he's a big star now
getting some imitations to play and it's
still very very young I believe he's 17
or maybe still 16 years old so it's over
2700 feet day so it's also very will be
interesting to watch him to see how he
will do what the Chinese team in the
upcoming Olympiad which is starting
tomorrow as I mentioned and if he has a
good performance that will certainly
help the team from China to win because
they are the current Olympic champions
so they went to this strong tournament
to try to regain their title of course
there is Russia in US this year who are
bigger the US yeah we're gonna cheer for
us so starting tomorrow 6 a.m. local
time you're it's in the games are played
in Baku Azerbaijan so but you can watch
the games online
I think ICC will have the games just 24
and so you'll be able to find that cheer
on the you
steam so we have a little bit time left
so we can do a couple of studies studies
your favorite studies remember okay
everybody this is the first exercise for
you it's white to play and win this
study was composed 102 years ago in 1914
by somebody named Mattie song Mattie's
from I don't know his name but these
people were not very well known chess
players but they're very good composers
so let's see now what can we do here to
win this possession and this one is not
that hard actually there is you're gonna
be able to find a win so just yes yes if
you get a position that's a very good
thought actually if you lose the if he
sacrifices the rook for this fun it's a
theoretical draw because we cannot
promote this country it's a wrong color
okay
so what can you do here well you just
mentioned that kindess six he just gives
you a check put sort of behind the
sacrifices and then he is gonna claim a
draw
kinga five unfortunately he might be
able to get back you know like to create
and Brooks no not to see one but King f5
maybe rope h1 Martin and then he goes
back yes correct are correct start I
walk in v7 now but your follow up needs
to be very precise as well a seven
correct follow up takes your pond now
threatening your bishop and also
threatening to get back rook e8 Mookie
eight
you cannot play that most casual way it
needs to be calculated remember serious
calculation needed he's threatening to
win your Bishop if you promote the pawn
into a queen you actually lose he takes
your bishop check you move the King
takes your as I stake you very much he
actually wins the game
Bishop h7 by Claudia okay now if he
takes to the rook you Quinn in the win
but what if he takes with the king he
wants to get behind you and still get
you with rookie three what are we going
to do here huh
King what cd4 check check check
another check are you really making any
progress here ah correct my cloud you
move up there you go and now King is on
the way exactly and no more check
no more check here okay you understand
now what about this move here what if he
says you know what I'm not gonna take it
I'm not gonna take it that he just goes
here he refuses to take that bishop but
wants to get behind it and when you're
Queen what are you going to do now
please don't trash you're trying to win
the game not to draw the game if you
walk in the sixth rookie one I don't
think you have chances to win I'll
sacrifice my rook for the last pond and
then King efore unfortunately you put
your King to the wrong square and now
this is gonna be a problematic move for
you okay don't give up yet don't give up
yet okay that's why we're doing this
good stuff here so you can you can see
the ideas huh
which p3 Martin he goes look eight and
rookie eight but your idea is right you
have to just do another move first okay
don't you wanna lie okay rook e8 idea
King a4 by cloud you're correct now if
you go rook here he goes Bishop e3 so he
has to go check and now what's the move
here what is the correct move here the
victory here you need this move here to
find the victory yes excellent bishop f2
now he takes check
it goes back what they do you win the
game exactly so that's the idea check
check and to win this okay all right
we're gonna do one more
okay this position looks troublesome
right for white because you got to
connected past pawn going down the road
and accommodated by a strong bishop here
so it looks like it's just a matter of
time until these new connectors will
decide outcome of this game but the good
news is it's your turn and maybe maybe
you can create something you can turn
these things around here pawns are going
this direction always look at the
numbers if it's 1 & 2 that means these
pawns are going this way if it's 1 & 2
here the black pawns are going the other
direction if you see the letters then
you always know which way the pawns are
moving forward white to play and save
this game ok save this game
you have to see the entire thing though
I would like you to see the entire
solution the entire solution I want not
just I want to make sure we can do this
in our head it's very clever it's very
clever solution it's not an ordinary
like you check take and you just stop my
point is your solution including
something extraordinary some kind of
brilliant idea
aha then you probably don't have it if
it's not something brilliant in it then
you don't have because this solution
could only be done by playing brilliant
and I want to make sure you see the
entire thing it's one two three four
five five moves it ends with a brilliant
finish that you will probably like I
don't want to just do like one by one
because then it will lose the effect of
the study you know when we go one by one
it's sometimes it's not as effective as
calculating everything you guys at the
level where you can find these things
you know I think it's hard but you can
strong strong players here one thing is
clear if you have two pounds you're not
going to be able to stop them so it's a
hint for either two connected task
phones you cannot stop so you got to
think about the eliminating one okay
what's the first of all the entire thing
Wow she's claiming she has the entire
solution cloudy oh you don't have
Claudia doesn't have very strong players
he doesn't know it yet okay go
okay that's one I can't push the palm
because you go check on you take it so I
gotta go check on Bravo but I'm a
correct solution here
what is your rating in 1800 what managed
to solve very good good job okay
excellent
excellent job Bravo I mean you should do
more studies again I every every time I
recommend you to do studies okay a trick
for you if you see or a the opponent is
getting a draw here right you have to be
smart about it and play the correct move
here to avoid the immediate draw here
which move will be to avoid the
immediate draw here that you're gonna
play the one rule under promotion and
this way we can test them whether or not
he knows how to draw this position even
some very strong grandmasters have
difficulty making a draw I want this
position against a strong Grandmaster
actually so it's it's I mean no it's
still a draw here but what I'm saying
was it's it's not a trivial draw here I
mean it's a draw but you have to really
know what you're doing here otherwise
you could not make a draw here so let's
make sure everybody in this room now
will be able to do this so what's the
first mode yeah you correct Martin yes
takes check f8 remember you have you
have to hide on f8 to be able to create
the still made mekinese now what is the
next value ya know he played here what's
the move he for you meanie 493 he
creates gets into a queen and now
the rock before Martin correct he takes
and don't worry we call this position
still may remember you have the still
mate idea to make trolls not only the
positions where there is no material to
win so steel made you can create and
make draws okay another thing is if you
see it's gonna be a stalemate you go d1
rook okay and it's gonna be a job I mean
it's it might still be a TRO but I think
this way still black and try to push you
can torture me for another fifty moves
here if he knows how to hold good for
him drop if not you likely to win I've
one wants this position yes alright well
we will cover this probably next time
because it's not so easy there's no your
one-way but you basically have to
remember one trick okay
one of the tricks in this position is so
let me just show you when he has a rook
right one of the defensive tricks in
this position is yeah so let's say he
goes here one of the defensive tricks
here in a position like this when he's
about to meet you okay
when you're about to get made it or
something you have this trick you have
to remember this trick rook f7 or
similar trick that if it takes it's
stalemate so again it still mate again
comes yeah if you don't if you don't
notice the defensive resource you you
will get made it so this is actually a
very important part of your defense this
idea okay so remember that but yeah we
can talk about this position he had
fifty moves to win this position when it
arrives if you don't win 850 moves it's
a theoretical draw my opponent actually
defended very well and he was only a few
moves away from a draw and then he made
the blunder and that happened and he
made a blunder and I had enough time to
finish him up otherwise it would have
been a drop so very interesting
no no it happens actually it happens I
think sometimes players see it's 50
moves they actually even make a bad move
but they just say arbiter 50 moves they
claim a draw because it's 50 moves you
have so if you can fix it and 50 moves
with the draw okay from as soon as you
reach this like this position as soon as
you put a rope right you have 50 moves
to win this position yeah yeah so you
have only 50 moves to win this position
if you don't win your 50 moves without
exchanging the bishop or the rook then
it's going to be a draw